[Musique]
bonsoir à tous c'est le début d'une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
avec atv 78 lors du 7-8 journal de la
rédaction tout de suite les titres de ce
lundi 24 septembre elle a fait sa
rentrée politique dans la seule ville le
frontiste d'île de france marine le pen
et et hier à mantes-la-ville dans un
moment difficile financièrement et
judiciairement pour sa formation la
présidente du rassemblement national est
venu célébrer elle a fait du drapeau
nouveau rendez-vous du parti le ministre
de l'action et des comptes publics
également dans les yvelines vendredi
gérald darmanin était de passage à marly
le roi objectif faire de la pédagogie et
expliquer les principales mesures
prévues dans le budget 2010 9 l an
prochain une baisse de six milliards
d'euros d'impôts est notamment prévu
pour les ménages
et puis ce sera notre fil rouge cette
semaine le premier dossier de la
rédaction est consacré à l'alimentation
de nos enfants à l'école et nous partons
ce soir dans plusieurs lycées du
département qui favorisent les produits
bio et locaux et des zélés des invités
est également dans ce journal on parle
des prix des deux du prix des talents de
la création d'entreprise l'une des
lauréates a été incubés à la couveuse la
du bg yvelines ont fait le point aussi
sur les besoins en dons du sang en ce
mois de septembre c'est à suivre dans ce
journal
marine le pen était donc ce dimanche à
mantes la ville pour célébrer la fête du
drapeau c'est un nouvel événement du
rassemblement national est la commune
est reine était l'occasion pour la
présidente du parti de marquer sa
rentrée politique c'est dans l'une des
rares communes frontiste de france
reportage d'isabelle carré isco la
présidente du rassemblement national en
terrain conquis ce dimanche à mantes la
ville unique communes d'île de france
ayant un maire est reine
la ville était une opportunité pour
marine le pen de ranimer des militants
encore sonné par l'échec à la
présidentielle en difficultés
financières et judiciaires
le rassemblement national fait sa
rentrée régionales dans une commune dont
la mairie discrète se veut servir
d'exemple pour l'ensemble du territoire
c'est aussi une vitrine de ce qu'on est
capable de faire la part du politique
d'un point de vue local sur la sécurité
sur le développement la vie culturelle
sur la non augmentation des impôts pour
les militants locaux la visite de leur
présidente jamais venu auparavant dans
la commune est une opportunité
électorale pour le département on a de
plus en plus départements qui sont
favorables à marine le pen
on espère en gagner de plus en plus à
monza a été un grand centre pour le
front national
elle s'est toujours occupé de
l'immigration je pense qu'il y en a
beaucoup trop en france c'est certain et
que si elle pouvait faire quelque chose
j'ai rien contre eux il en faut
malheureusement puisque les femmes ne
veulent plus faire d'enfants avec
seulement une dizaine de communes et
rennes en france marine le pen marquer
le coup avec manque la ville malgré les
honneurs faits au maire cyril notes et à
sa commune la présidente était de courts
passages et n'aura pas rencontré ses
habitants politique toujours le budget
2010 9 a été présenté ce matin en
conseil des ministres il prévoit l'an
prochain notamment une baisse d'impôts
de 6 milliards d'euros pour les ménages
et la poursuite de la suppression de la
taxe d'habitation des mesures défendues
par gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics étaient
à marly-le-roi en fin de semaine
dernière sur invitation de la députée
des yvelines marie le bec
reportage de nicolas landry le ministre
des comptes publics face aux yvelinois
gérald darmanin est venu défendre les
mesures budgétaires prévue pour 2019
comme la poursuite de la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation accompagné d'une
réforme de la fiscalité locale en cours
de réflexion
sa vieille impôts une égalité entre les
citoyens entre les communes c'est pas la
même chose de recettes fiscales attraper
et à versailles par exemple évidemment
essayer de spécialiser les fiscalités
par collectivité la tva pour la région
la csg pour le département la commune
plutôt la taxe foncière quand vous vous
êtes propriétaire
c'est un débat que nous propose au fond
on avait trop congrès des maires de
france aux élus pour que nous puissions
discuter à chaque collectivité sa
recette fiscale l'idée de cette réforme
prévue pour février 2019 les élus locaux
ont des attentes précises vis-à-vis de
l'état on a engagé nous depuis plusieurs
années des plans de réduction des
dépenses des plans au cid de recherche
d'économies dans tous de tous les côtés
on veut bien si vous voulez porter cet
effort d'économie qui est un effort
d'économie qui porte toute la nation
mais il faut que l'état lui même à son
niveau fasse des efforts qu'ils soient à
la hauteur des mêmes efforts qui demande
aux communes autre point dans le projet
de loi de finances 2010 9 la
transformation du crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi
baisses de charges pour les entreprises
mais nous mettons 20 milliards de
transformation du sehy ce fameux
subvention que l'état versé aux
entreprises en baisse de charge serpro
fait la baisse structurelle d'impôts et
l'année prochaine par exemple une
entreprise pour embaucher quelqu'un au
smic à zéro euro plutôt que d'attendre
un an donc pour nous c'est ça va pas
nous faire gagner d'argent ça va pas
nous faire perdre mais en terme de
gestion d'entreprise c'est plus
intéressant
le gouvernement a jusqu'au mardi 2
octobre 2018 pour déposer le projet de
loi de finances à l'assemblée nationale
on parle encore d'économie avec deux
invités qui m'ont rejoint en plateau
marie-dominique roseaux libon soir dans
ça va être la responsable de la couveuse
lab dubé jeu yvelines avec nous
également l'une de vos anciennes incubés
bonsoir golin solaire vous êtes la
présidente et cofondatrice de rec norrec
alors vous êtes récente lauréate du prix
talents de la création d'entreprise qui
a des gorilles innovations déjà pour
commencer cette c'est quoi ce prix pour
le présenter alors c'est un prix qui
visiblement pour la 20e édition
récompense des entreprises qui ont créé
leur activité dans la région et dans
d'autres régions de france
et là pour le coup pour ma part c'est la
catégorie innovation qu'a récompensé mon
projet et c'est un p tit re naissent par
le réseau béjaouis qu'elle est quelle
est votre réaction si vous êtes honoré
ça sera bien sûr oui et puis c'est une
forme de panneaux pas encore de
reconnaissance mais en tout cas de mise
en lumière de mon projet de la part de
la région ile-de-france comme ça un
projet qui a vocation à alimenter la
région en développement je crois que
c'est assez cohérent donc ça me fait
très plaisir
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte d'avoir ce
prix vous le disiez vous êtes encore
plus sûr dans votre démarche dans votre
projet votre entreprise non je dirais
pas ça mais c'est plutôt que je me sens
plus légitime
en fait peut-être peut-être et puis la
preuve de la persévérance on va dire non
je me sens plus légitime pour aller voir
la région
pour lui demander du soutien dans le
cadre du montage plus opérationnelle du
projet justement votre entreprise
rectorat quelques années son domaine
d'activité alors notre particularité est
que nous mettons en place une
organisation industrielle pour recycler
les déchets qui échappe aux filières de
recyclage aujourd'hui donc c'est une
solution technologique et
d'organisations qui permet de recycler
les déchets qui sont mélangés qui sont
sales qui sont difficiles à à trier ou
qui ont déjà fait l'objet d'un tri dans
des centres de tri et de les transformer
en un matériau comme ceux comme
échantillon que je présente ici avec
quelques objets loués sur ce plateau
oui il est des échantillons pour montrer
un peu la mise en forme et encore c'est
très limité de cette matière et donc
notre démarche vise à à peu près offrir
une solution alternative au centre
d'enfouissement et à l'incinération des
déchets d'accord mais qui a des
performances tout à fait similaire voire
supérieur à des filières de recyclage
habituel puisque puisqu'on passe
directement de ce mélange de déchets à
cette matière très solide et assez
original et vous êtes venus également il
ce trophée un des talents de remis par
le bep goethe à l'heure de jeu j'ai
perdu le nom talents de la création
d'entreprise pardon maric de dominique
rose au lit le fait oui qu'une ancienne
incubés soit soit récompensé c'est aussi
la preuve pour la couveuse la queue que
le travail est bien fait
l'accompagnement été bien fait en tout
cas dans ce cas là évidemment on est
extrêmement heureux pour hugo dins et
c'est à la fois une personne qui a des
compétences qui a des idées qui est
novatrice mme et avoir pu accompagner ce
projet dans une première phase parce que
l'accompagnement continue
c'était dans le cadre de la couveuse et
aujourd'hui golin fait partie du sky
cube dans le cadre d'un autre type
d'accompagnement pour nous c'est
vraiment une réussite et on a très bon
espoir pour la suite
parce que ce projet il a de multiples
dimensions évidemment hugo jean l'a dit
on est dans du recyclage de matériaux
mais c'est aussi un projet qui a une
forte notation sur les aspects sociétal
et environnemental
donc on est fier alors la couveuse avait
fêté à fêter cette année dix ans vous
avez d'ailleurs reçu à cette occasion
c'est quoi les objectifs d'une couveuse
alors les objectifs c'est à un moment
donné dans le cadre de son parcours de
création d'entreprise de tester son
activité et de voir jusqu'où on peut
aller et prendre la décision au final de
créer son entreprise qui a été le cas du
goal in même si on sait un parce que
c'est un projet qui est complexe qui est
technologiquement avancé que des tests y
en aura encore d'ailleurs elle vous l'a
pas dit mais elle part d'ici quelques
jours au brésil pour finaliser ces tests
et donc voilà qu'on veut c'est ça c'est
de permettre à des personnes de tester
leur projet pour s'immatriculer dans un
cadre légal avec un accompagnement
individualisé avec des formations et
puis avec la possibilité aussi de
facturer et puis une autre possibilité
qui est primordial notamment dans ce
type de projet technique c'est
d'utiliser un numéro siret qui vous
permet en fait d'interagir avec d'autres
professionnels et on voit au travers de
l'exemple de règle le rec d'hugo linke
il ya des sorties positives après après
cette expérience dans la couveuse lab
oui effectivement les sorties positives
sont nombreuses puisque presque près de
70 personnes
70% excusez moi des personnes qui sont
en couveuse vont créer leur activité
15 % vont retrouver un emploi donc ce
sont des
effectivement ce sont des dd tout qui
sont extrêmement intéressants et qui
sont possibles parce que on est dans un
cadre d'accompagnement renforcé
d'altitude nous reste 30 secondes
environ la suite là pour vous allez
partir au brésil c'est ça oui alors je
pars au brésil pour réceptionner les
minima chine donc la technologie échelle
très réduite et pour apprendre à m'en
servir avant de le rapatrier ici et je
me permets un appel très rapide puisque
vous avez certainement une audience très
développé je recherche à un atelier de
toute petite taille 1 30 mètre carré
dans les environs de saint quentin en
yvelines nord plaisir les clés et qu'ils
soient équipés de puissance électrique
donc voilà un atelier technique de
toutes petites canailles et qui sera
disposition pendant quelques mois pour
pouvoir mener les projets avant de
changer changer d'échelle
l'appel a été passé merci à vous d'avoir
été avec nous pour plus d'information
sur le dispositif de la couveuse du bg
ville je vous invite à vous rendre sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran
une conférence de presse axée en partie
sur la jeunesse le député des yvelines
didier baichère a fait le point sur les
dispositifs du gouvernement pour
l'insertion professionnelle cinq saint
quentinois ont par exemple trouver un
emploi via le plan 1000 jeunes et cette
année dans le département les 800
collégiens du réseau d'éducation
prioritaire renforcées vont pouvoir
expérimenter la plateforme à venir stage
troisième lancer dans le cadre du pacte
avec les quartiers pour toutes les
entreprises 30000 stages proposés en
france aux jeunes des quartiers
sensibles pour une première expérience
positive dans le monde du travail propos
collectées par michael et demi d'euros
mettre en relation les jeunes de 3e donc
ils sont dans des collèges reste plus
donc c'est réservé cette année reconnaît
serait plus et les entreprises donc
mettre des stages de qualité à des
jeunes qui souvent n'ont pas le réseau
nécessaire donc non pas des
connaissances d'entreprise pour faire
leur stage galère faut le dire pour
trouver un stage est donc cette
plateforme qui à la disposition des
collèges aurait plus va leur permettre
d'avoir accès à des offres auxquelles
ils n'avaient pas accès jusqu'à
maintenant
la plateforme est d'ores et déjà en
ligne pour consulter ces offres
rendez vous sur le site mon stage de
troisième point fr retour d'un rendez
vous réguliers à présent à la fin de
chaque mois la rédaction de tv 78
vous propose son dossier thématique
cette semaine nous nous intéressons à
l'alimentation de nos enfants à l'école
premier focus ce soir sur les lycées et
géré par l'île de france la région
continue de soutenir le bio 1 5 million
d'euros ont été injectés cette année
pour idier pour aider senlis et
introduire ces produits est favorisé le
circuit court marylène iapichino s'est
rendue dans deux d'entre eux pour cette
rentrée 2010 8 la région ile-de-france
veut que ces lycéens manger mieux et on
veut du produit local
et puis on veut que dans ce produit
local 50% soit du produit bio donc nous
allons travailler sur cet
approvisionnement senlis et cette année
seront concernés par l'introduction du
bio
l'augmentation des tarifs pour les
parents qui règne le repas de leurs
enfants suivant leur quotient familial
alors pour aider les lycées la région
finance à 40 % les produits bio et à 60%
le bio local au lycée 17 mar de maurepas
on essaie de servir du bio depuis six
ans objectif d'ici la fin de l'année
atteints dans les 10 % de produits bio
dans les plateaux pour obtenir ces
produits locaux le lycée fait appel au
groupement des agriculteurs bio d'île de
france
mais ce n'est pas toujours suffisant et
des moments où ils ont pas forcément
alors soit parce qu'on est trop nombreux
à recommander ou aux clivages n'ont pas
donné assez de lait et la semaine
dernière je n'ai pas eu toute ma
livraison
ils ont partagé quoi pour que tout le
monde puisse en avoir et pas eu toute la
livraison de yahoo j'avais demandé je
connais le plus de mal à trouver c'est
la viande car quand on parle
restauration scolaire on parle quantité
on passe à peu près 300 personnes en une
demi heure au maximum ce sont 600 repas
qui sont servis chaque jour d'ouverture
de la demi-pension au lycée jules ferry
de versailles
on explose les compteurs 1300 élèves
sont inscrits à la cantine
la plus grosse difficulté c'est de
trouver des agriculteurs ou des
commerçants qui sont prêts à jouer le
jeu sur le volume puisque si on prend
l'exemple des pommes de terre
aujourd'hui on est sur 350 kg de pommes
de terre pour servir autant de repas pas
moins de 200 fait une organisation bien
rodée donc nos cuisines fait une
production à la minute au fur et à
mesure que les élèves avant sous les
personnes qui sont à blâmer nations
avancent on leur fait de la production
on réajuste au plus près de façon
ne pas perdre le gâchis et avant un
produit sain et de qualité servie chaude
ici le mot d'ordre est locale le chef de
cuisine s'est rapproché de ses collègues
investi par les mêmes envies de circuits
courts pour créer un réseau en 2012 nous
allons monter l'action toqués du local
qui était d une réfection de consommer
des produits qu'on trouvait autour de
nous en ile de france puisque bien
souvent on va chercher des produits très
loin alors que en ile de france et un
dos très bon produit
que ce soit la volaille en poids en
fruits et légumes en produits laitiers
ce jour là c'est la fête de la
gastronomie l'occasion parfaite de
mettre en avant des produits les plus
locaux possibles des moules de normandie
des produits laitiers de la ferme de
grignon et du raisin français de
différentes variétés
allez on se fait ça au total 20 % des
lycéens franciliens ont des produits bio
dans leurs plateaux on accueille sur ce
plateau notre deuxième invité stéphane
noël bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous est le directeur de l'établissement
français du sang d'île de france ont
fait le point avec vous sur les besoins
du moment en don du sang cette actualité
d'abord le ffs a suspendu il ya quelques
jours l utilisation d'un matériel de
prélèvement de la marque haemonetics il
assurait une technique de prélèvement
par aphérèse comment fonctionne cette
technique
écoutez cette technique est une
technique relativement simple il s'agit
de prendre le sang du donneur qui vient
chez nous pour prélever en l'occurrence
avec cette technique du plasma se sont
réfugiés dans un bol à usage unique y
est un bol stérile et ce bol à usage
unique permet de centrifuge et le sens
pour que nous collectons le plasma il
nous restitue en d'honneur les éléments
du sens qu dont nous n'avons pas besoin
en l'occurrence les globules rouges et
les plaquettes
cette technique que nous avons pris la
décision de l'arrêter tout simplement
parce que nous étions dans une logique
de principe de précaution et nous avons
eu des suspicions par rapport à
l'utilisation de cette technique il faut
savoir que notre priorité absolue c'est
la sécurité des donneurs la sécurité des
patients et à partir du moment où nous
avons le moindre doute sur l'utilisation
d'une technique et bien nous arrêtons de
l'utiliser il faut savoir que cette
technique de prélèvement de plasma
haemonetics est une technique largement
utilisé au niveau de l'ue
ce niveau national alors nous
n'utilisions pas cette technique en
ile-de-france ont averti qu'ils ont une
autre marque
mais nous avons d'autres types de de
séparateurs pour faire ce type de
prélèvement en ile de france nous
utilisons notamment pour prélever des
plaques end et nous sommes en constante
veille en constante surveillance de ses
équipements afin d'adapter en permanence
en fonction des signaux dont nous
disposons la stratégie la meilleure
stratégie possible
étant entendu que la sécurité des
donneurs là sa rééducation
c'est absolument nécessaire et c'est une
technique primordial vital cette
technique de prélèvement par aphérèse
alors effectivement c'est une technique
qui est importante notamment s'agissant
de la production de plaquettes il faut
savoir que les plaquettes ont cinq jours
de durée de vie en ile de france nous
produisons à peu près la moitié de nos
plaquettes sur des techniques d'aphérèse
nous avons à peu près la moitié de notre
parc qui est une marque haemonetics nous
avons une autre technique avec une autre
marque et chacune des techniques
représente à peu près 25% de la
production des plaquettes en ile de
france et le reste des plaquettes est
produite grâce au sang total que nous
prenions tous les jours auprès de nos
donneurs et 100 pour cette raison qu'il
absolument essentielle tous les jours de
donner son sang comme donnions notre
sang nous pouvons soigner trois patients
nous fabriquons trois produits avec une
poche de sang qui est prélevé chez un
donneur il faudrait combien de dons par
jour de dons par mois pour assurer les
stocks alors idéalement en ile de france
il faudrait mille 700 dons par jour dans
les journées qui fonctionne bien nous
prélevons à peu près en ile-de-france
1000 dons par jour en ile de france nous
dépendons fortement de la province parce
que nous n'arrivons pas à prélever le
nombre de dons nécessaires chaque jour
il faut savoir qu'actuellement
quand je dis il faut à peu près 1000
dons par jour en ile de france
actuellement nous sommes à peu près 20%
dessous notre objectif à ce que les
donneurs ne se mobilisent peut-être pas
suffisamment aujourd'hui donc c'est pour
ça que je profite de votre émission et
jour merci nous allons il faut lancer un
appel afin que les donneurs viennent
viennent donner il important de venir
donner que ce soit du sang total sur
l'ensemble des collectes que nous
organisons mais également d'autres types
de produits comme les plaquettes ou le
plasma 7 sont primordiales pour prendre
en charge les besoins des patients
toutes les informations à retrouver bien
sûr sur le site internet de la fff
ile de france alors et on s'éclate et en
général c'est une période où il ya moins
est-ce que l'été 2018 a dérogé à cette
règle est ce que les dons étaient plus
nombreux est ce qu'aujourd'hui du coup
les stocks sont au vert quand elle est
la situation est telle et et 2018 a été
a été un été particulièrement compliqué
notamment on a eu la coupe du monde qui
a fait que pendant une période les
donneurs ont peut-être été plus assidus
devant la télé notamment parce que la
france ait eu la chance d'aller très
loin dans cette compétition
ensuite nous avons vécu une période très
difficile du fait de la canicule la
canicule a été très longue cette année
elle a été très lourde à la fois pour le
personnel et pour les donneurs et nous
avons une moindre fréquentation ce qui
fait que nous abordons aujourd'hui la
rentrée dans qui est dans une situation
qui est tendu voire très tendu et donc
pour cette raison une nouvelle fois nous
avons besoin que les donneurs se
mobilisent se mobilise fortement sur nos
sites fixes à versailles aux chaînés et
à quoi si nous avons deux sites fixes et
puis également sur l'ensemble des
collectes mobiles et comme vous l'avez
dit on peut retrouver des informations
sur nos collections mobile sur notre
site internet
merci stéphane noël d'avoir été avec
nous je rappelle que vous êtes le
directeur régional de l'établissement
français du sang d'ile-de-france pour la
paix une à la fois toutes les
informations à retrouver sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
c'est l'un des plus grands événements
sportifs du moment la ryder cup débute
demain au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pendant la
compétition tiger woods rory mcilroy ou
encore phil mikelson seront logés à
versailles à l'hôtel du trianon palace
on va peut-être le voir en images ça y
est
tout comme l'ensemble des équipes et
staff européens et américains les
premières arrivées ont eu lieu hier et
se poursuivent aujourd'hui le début des
entraînements est fixée à demain et la
compétition officielle
elle se déroule à partir de vendredi
d'ailleurs toute cette semaine tv
soixante dix huit vous proposera des
émissions spéciales ryder cup depuis le
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines
voici le programme détaillé premier
numéro ce soir à 18h45
rediffusion à 19h45 et 23h15 le problème
de les afficher
ça y est ça s'affiche voilà vous avez
les horaires des émissions premier
numéro ce soir 18h45 rediffusion 19h45
et 23h15 une émission qui sera présenté
ce soir par
wilfrid riches y est vous le retrouverez
également aux manettes de ses émissions
spéciales ryder cup michael et demi
d'euros bonsoir bonsoir grégory c'est
dans vos habitudes désormais avant votre
7,8 sport vous venez nous présenter les
principaux résultats du week-end dans le
département et les franciliens michael
ont mis leurs chaussures de running ce
week end
oui de la course à pied mais pas
n'importe quelle course
grégory ont fêté ce week-end la 41e
édition du paris versailles course
mythique de 16 km qui relie la tour
eiffel au château versailles et en
passant par la redoutable côte des
gardes à meudon vous la connaissez bien
grégory cette année 25 mille coureurs
ont pris le départ de l'épreuve le
vainqueur et lui burundais abraham
niyonkuru s'est détaché dans le sprint
final pour s'imposer en cinquante et une
minutes et trente et une secondes on
écoute le vainqueur ça me fait preuve et
après vous gagnez tout à coup les trois
années d'affilée toyoda vienne chez les
féminines c'est l'éthiopienne hochart
acquerra qui l'emportent
à 22 ans la sportive franchi la ligne
d'arrivée en 1h01 et 35 secondes
elle devance la française laurie
lindekens de deux minutes tout ce beau
monde devrait se retrouver l'année
prochaine pour une 42e édition du paris
versailles
on range les basques et de running
michael on sort les ballons ovales vous
parler rugby à présent exactement le
ballon ovale commencé alors manqué et ça
s'est vu dans le championnat de division
honneur versailles faisait sa rentrée
sur le tard de monter sion après une
pause estivale et les versaillais ont
remporté leur premier match dans la
douleur en s'imposant 21 à 18 une
victoire qui permet de lancer la saison
du rcv qui vise cette année une montée
en fédérale 3 avec un gros recrutement
effectué à l'intersaison
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile au stade de porchefontaine
contre le roc j fois toujours dans le
championnat de division honneur le ska
et rugby a repris son championnat par un
festival offensif avec à la clé victoire
26 à saintes sur le terrain de melun
combs senart 77 au classement cette
victoire lors de cette première journée
permet aux saint quentinois de prendre
la place de leader prochain match
dimanche prochain à 15 heures sur le
teint de vaucresson un bon dimanche pour
les rugbymans yvelinois handball est ce
que les féminines
montigny le bretonneux ont aussi connu
la victoire et oui grégory à
montigny-le-bretonneux ca largement
imposés ce week-end pour leur premier
match de la saison à domicile dans cette
nationale 2 lésigny monteyne en dominer
patronage laïque granville handball sur
le score de 31 à 23
un festival offensif qui permet aux
joueuses de denys choulet de remonter à
la 9e place du classement après deux
journées avec un bilan à l'équilibré
d'une victoire il défaite depuis le
début de la saison
merci michael toutes ces infos et bien
d'autres encore à retrouver dans
quelques instants
votre émission le 7-8 sport juste après
le journal on va terminer ce journal
avec la vallée de chevreuse direction la
vallée de chevreuse ou un poète et
élèves en formation horticole ont pu
travailler ensemble le nom de ce projet
trait d'union entre la maison triolet
aragon et la fondation le notre
reportage de jules colis c'est au
château de pinceloup as ton chant que se
prépare un événement bien particulier
mêlant poésie et nature soutenu par le
parc régional de la vallée de chevreuse
le projet trait d'union propose une
collaboration entre artistes poètes de
la maison triolet aragon et jeunes
élèves de la fondation le nôtre par le
biais d'ateliers poésie la maison
triolet aragon intervient au château de
pinceau et sur trois jours pour proposer
des ateliers autour de la poésie avec
l'idée de créer une bande sonore qui
mêlerait à la fois des sons que les
élèves de l'école lenôtre ou qui a ses
locaux dans les murs du château de
pinceau va aller capter dans le parc et
les différents espaces dans lesquels ils
travaillent et qui seront ensuite
assemblés à la voix de ces mêmes élèves
récitant des textes donc aux différents
poèmes de différentes époques qui tous
sont liés par une même thématique
d'une part il ya un premier travail de
défrichage qui est fait pour favoriser
la compréhension puisque les élèves
auprès desquels nous intervenons ne sont
pas francophones
voici les images j'ai rappelé à savoir
plus a fait un match c'est enfin un
travail difficile mélangeant littérature
et environnement que ces étudiants en
horticulture aborde avec un grand
enthousiasme mais j'en ai six ont
plusieurs projets du coup en cours tout
cette année ils étaient en classe
préparatoire
ils ont donc beaucoup travaillé dans la
serre qui se trouve là juste à côté ils
ont fait beaucoup de bouturage de ce
miseront a pris avec leurs éducateurs
les différentes techniques valeur permet
la fois donc d'être dans une position
d'apprenants mais aussi d'être vraiment
acteur dans la mesure où par exemple la
prise de son en extérieur leur permet de
montrer leur travail les lieux qu'ils
fréquentent pas ça a été plutôt positif
les jeunes se sont montrés motivés plus
tôt investi certains jeunes ont mémorisé
leurs poèmes ce que je ne pensais pas au
départ c'est des poèmes qui sont quand
même pour beaucoup assez compliquée du
victor hugo du rimbaud etc mais ils se
sont intéressés au projet un projet fait
avec le coeur mélangeant installations
graphique et sonore qui prendra place le
8 octobre gratuitement dans les couloirs
du château
c'est la fin de ce journal belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]